hi I'm Greg Dima Shelley I'm a director
of product management here at Google and
I work on the Google cloud platform
today we have some exciting news about
compute engine we want to share with you
compute engine is Google's virtual
machine technology it allows you to run
any type of application you want on top
of Google's infrastructure and data
centers now the cloud platform also
includes App Engine which is our
platform as a service offering that lets
you easily build and scale web apps or
mobile backends we also have a variety
of storage products from sequel to no
sequel databases and all of these are
managed and operated by Google using our
15 years of expertise in building
hardware and software infrastructure and
if you take it all together they give
you the flexibility you need to build
and deploy virtually any type of
application but today we're here to talk
about compute engine this is a big day
for compute engine and for the cloud
platform because we've reached a new
milestone I'm excited to announce that
compute engine has reached general
availability what that means is you now
have virtual machines that have the
performance reliability security and
scale of Google's own infrastructure in
addition to customer support and a high
monthly SLA this milestone represents
our internal and external commitment to
the service and to delivering to you a
great developer experience we have over
a thousand engineers working on
continuing to make the cloud platform
better for Google itself and for you our
customers now before we go too far in
looking at new features that we're
announcing let me give you a tour of
just what sort of performance and
reliability you can expect from compute
engine this is a little app that will
spawn a number of compute engine virtual
machines in this case I'm going to have
it start 1,000 virtual machines when I
click start it's using the compute
engine API to launch those virtual
machines and it has a timer running to
keep track of how long it took as the
virtual machines are launched the boxes
turn from grey to green indicating that
the VM is launched successfully now
this will take a couple minutes to
launch these thousand virtual machines
so we're gonna let that run in the
background while I continue to talk to
you a bit let's talk about some of the
new features that we're announcing today
first compute engine now supports
transparent maintenance windows what
this means is that as we do the
maintenance and upgrades whether it's
software or hardware or networking in
our data centers your application
continues to run unimpaired
we move your virtual machine out of the
way while we're performing the
maintenance you get the benefits of an
up-to-date maintained patched data
center without having the impact on your
applications this is available today in
our United States data centers and we'll
be rolling it out to Europe shortly in
addition we have automatic restarts this
means in the event of an unplanned event
or a hardware failure your application
will restart as quickly as possible this
was a commonly requested feature from
many of our customers including some of
our enterprise customers
now turning to operating systems until
now we've supported Debian and Sint OS
based virtual machines well today we're
opening that up not only can you run
FreeBSD you can run any out-of-the-box
Linux distro and with one click in the
admin console you can launch sousei or
Red Hat virtual machines directly SUSE
and Red Hat are in limited preview and
the other Linux distros are available
today
we've also added new more powerful
compute engine instance types we know
there's customers out there who want to
run even more demanding compute
intensive applications so starting today
you can launch virtual machines with up
to 16 cores these are available in our
standard high CPU and high memory
configurations M this means you can
bring even more demanding loads onto
compute engine now of course app
performance isn't just about number of
cores and memory it also is about disk
performance we know from talking to
customers that persistent disk
performance is a key factor so starting
today persist
disk is up to eight times faster this
means you can now bring your more i/o
intensive and disk intensive workloads
to compute engine and have a great
experience running those as well now
before we go on let's go over and see
how those virtual machines that we
started up or doing here we are we're
back and all the boxes have turned green
which means all thousand VMs are up and
running and if we look at the time it
was two minutes 41 seconds that's a
pretty quick way to start a thousand VMs
so in addition to new features we also
continue to support major enterprise
customers we have 24 by 7 support a
monthly SLA of 99.95%
so you have guarantees of uptime as well
as important certifications such as ISO
27001 or sauk one two and three finally
we're continuing to pass on the savings
from building and operating ever more
efficient data centers
we're also reaffirming our commitment to
offer the best compute price performance
we're doing that by lowering prices on
our most popular instance type by 10%
across-the-board in all regions we've
also heard from customers that cost
predictability and i/o performance are
key factors for persistent disk so not
only are we making it 8 times faster
we're making it up to 60% cheaper
we're also eliminating any charge for
i/o you simply purchase the capacity you
need and you get great io for free you
get way more performance at a great and
predictable price of course when you're
building an application support for
partners and is fees is critical the
ecosystem around compute engine is large
and growing quickly the software you're
familiar with whether it's from write
scale or scaler new relic map our Mongo
labs all runs great
on Google cloud platform Google cloud
platform gives you the performance
reliability scalability and security
that we expect from our own applications
you can get started today with compute
engine and the Google cloud platform
just go to cloud google.com sign up for
a new account and you can start creating
applications
you know one of the most fun things
about working on the cloud platform is
seeing the amazing apps that you the
developers create so I hope you'll go
out create some great applications
engage with us on Google+ or any of the
other social networks we love hearing
about what you've built with the
platform thanks for listening